I just get I have a hard time believing
you won't kill me after the deeds done
that's the other thing too right if you
don't help me and you say something I'm
gonna kill you
[Music]
uh Nick do you know any good ways to
um get away with murder
um you got anything in the pocket here
this is this is what you do okay uh
whenever you feel like you have an urge
to commit murder you just don't do it
that's a good one so abstin invention is
better than cure huh is that
all right number two
with a knife
to get away with to get away with murder
yeah let somebody else do it I watched
Ozark
or you just gotta have I think
if you commit murder you have to plan
like six months in advance dude but what
if only six months plans suck I feel
like you gotta plan your whole life
that's true six months of preparation
to make sure you have all the stuff
before you commit them I think at least
minimum that's true yeah you can't buy
anything I think you got to be very
prepared okay and you got to practice a
lot a lot of hard work a lot of
dedication you got to go out there okay
what type of killer would you be
man are you more like a a Dexter type of
killer or more like I would like to
think I'd be a Dexter type of killer but
I could very well see myself
lose a little control and then just kill
people just because they annoyed me as
somebody who just uses do you think you
get caught if you killed what I think
you would get caught yeah me I probably
I'd probably get caught I think you turn
yourself off I think Nick I think
planned Nick plans for a year and then
he gets impatient and mad and does it in
a month
the only person that would really be
successful at this table because I I
don't really know everyone I
I don't know too much about you but
maybe Colleen just because here we go
it's very like I can see it meticulous
so can I say something else too I think
she's already done it in the past I
think she's ready I don't know I know I
don't know but I think he'll find out I
wouldn't be so I wouldn't be surprised
if she was like oh yeah I got like two
already under my belt
I got two bodies I'd be like I'd be
initially shocked but then I think about
it I go oh that makes sense
I can see that so there's this um this
woman named Nicole Max she's 35 she's a
resident of Daytona Beach
she committed first-degree murder
against her roommate I don't understand
these rich people doing this
uh she kills a 79 year old dude who I
guess was her roommate but they're not
but they're rich I don't know you can
tell me when you look at her photo but
she stabs this guy to death all right
this is what she looks like that's her
sugar daddy it's her sugar daddy no no
no oh do the girl she doesn't what is
her neck tattoo stab her I don't know
damn dude it hurt this from this does it
match down two times twelve what does
that mean
this yeah from here down to me looks
like she dates extreme sports guys from
here up it looks like she's at Starbucks
yelling about the wrong order
uh Karen like that wait you said this is
Daytona it's like like yeah that looks
like uh she's at Food For Less shopping
for her family
that looks like she's also at Food For
Less shopping for her nice
she I guess to cover it up she tried to
like set the house on fire oh dude
that's not good you can't do it that's a
bad one you get way more kinds of
Investigations yeah you kill them you
gotta do gas leak baby the the house
with stoves on and then you think wait
did she does away with the body so she
can't no she leaves the body there and
she tries to start a fire allegedly to
make it look like oh he doesn't avoid or
whatever but that's all the stab works
they're like investigating and they find
um they like find a knife next to her
phone so they're like okay exhibit a
that's that but the whole thing didn't
burn down is that why no I didn't all
burn down she should have blew up the
house like on the ring camera yeah
that's the way to do it
yeah but she [__] she [__] up
pointed to the wrong house
damn dude I know like [__] so then uh
detectives go to try to track her down
they find her outside a restaurant
nearby and she's um when they catch her
she like drops a hammer and a knife oh
no what she had in her hand so there you
go oh no they uh she also didn't have
any shoes on she had blood on her leg
she gave conflicting stories that didn't
make sense refuses to uh speak without a
lawyer so what they did was they take
her into custody and she asks for a
drink
they give her a Mountain Dew took her
DNA from there
so we get him she first 48. at this
point believing that oh man these guys
are gonna ask for my DNA they're gonna
be able to match it with the DNA on the
knife blah blah blah so she comes up
with the idea to take the Mountain Dew
and completely douse herself with it
smart try to erase the DNA smart
because it's all over her now they can't
they can't get a sample from that
smart yeah that's true all they'll get
is baa black yeah yeah all spilled and
you know spilled everywhere so yeah so
she would I mean I wouldn't she asked
for Mountain Dew I wouldn't question it
she does seem like a Mountain Dew
Drinker yeah like it fits the
demographic she looks like she'll ask
for surge yeah she's doing code red
orange yeah so she dumps this she dumps
him out and do as an attempt to
interfere with the DNA on her body on
her own body she's trying to scrub
herself from his DNA apparently because
she has blood stains knowing that no
they're trying to get your DNA you
[__] idiot yeah so they can match it
with the crime scene I like her why a 79
year old she's what was the point she
couldn't be a little more patient right
he was about to croak anyway yeah he's
right there
I think that's when you push someone
down the stairs bruh you know right you
go with the uh maybe suffocate him in
bed yeah
I have a stairs aren't guaranteed
because he might live after that's true
that's true maybe that a cliff go hiking
together yeah honestly I think if
I keep hearing about people saying that
um
like in big old places like the
Everglades right yeah they find dead
bodies in there they find all kinds of
crazy [__] I would just take a trip and
they can't they can't do a trade so it's
like you gotta live in a very wild I
think you got to find some crocodiles
dude I think that's your best bet just
[__] Crocs gotta find some Crocs and I
think you can kill somebody you just
dump the body there this lady that
killed herself like that she threw
herself into a crocodile pit damn
suicide by crocodile um
at least you're feeding them yeah kind
of you're not going to waste right
yeah that's a this is a whole thing is a
bad plan so they they eventually test
take her DNA and they match it with the
DNA on the knife and they're like okay
yeah you killed them so the Mountain Dew
stuff was totally unnecessary so did she
call the police ah I got you coppers she
called the police correct no but because
she set fire this is like everything you
shouldn't do yeah because she set fire
to the apartment as a way to uh cover
the body that made an instant emergency
response to the address because and so
she wasn't done cleaning up and then
they came it's an apartment so someone's
gonna call the fire department so now
you know you get them there even quicker
than if someone was he could have had
like a whole day to like exactly
everything to get why do you have to set
it on fire like right then yeah you
could have waited yeah honestly if you
want to get away with murder you
probably have to kill someone completely
random
because look this is this is my thought
right if you look at all the best serial
killers what makes them so successful
there's no connection there's no
connection they're random they live in a
[__] different town and they're
they're honestly they're picking people
that are not generally missed yeah like
hookers or family and on top of that too
they're they're hella they're they're
they're extra creepy about how they they
they go about their whole process you
know they stop for a long time they're
really twisted and they're coming they
played a long game and I feel like those
are your keys to success when you want
to get away with successful murder right
no is that crazy all you want to do is
kill a person yeah but like but you want
to kill someone that's close to you you
I don't think you could do it yeah do
you think you can't physically do it
that's smart that goes back to what Joe
said yeah that's true but maybe
um assassins would know
like they gotta do it for work you're
gonna ask the professor they gotta be
doing it well but how many times do we
sit here and it's like somebody goes on
the web Google's assassin pays them 300
bucks to go murder somebody and then
that person's like a cop but that's
because they don't oh yeah but they also
don't have nordvpn they're sloppy with
how they go about it yeah you got to do
everything through they also don't have
better help yeah
rage Shadow Legends yeah dude and when
you get all nervous you need Loom dude
you need Lumi bro or taskrabbit yeah
taskrabbit it you start sweating
Everywhere You Gotta use the loom did
you see there's like a there was an old
Vice talk about a Hitman from Mexico and
he was talking about how the process
works and he said that like if you want
to hire him you provide the weapon like
you buy the the weapon and then you uh
you give him the target so what if I
give him like a flute and say be
creative let's just shove it up his ass
and kill it you choke him with her it's
probably gonna cost more yeah yeah Style
videos I like your style
you give them an acoustic guitar and
you're like this is the weapon so if you
guys come in here to murder is there
someone that you could trust to do it no
to tell
it's definitely a dude not a chick yeah
I told my wife I was like if would you
telling me if I if I kill somebody and
you knew about it she'd be like yeah so
I can't tell her yeah it probably
Anthony's right I think you have to tell
I pick Anthony
you know what would be the worst thing
is if you pick a homie right like say
that's your your North Carolina only
right you're like hey dude like um I
killed somebody and he goes
I killed somebody
that [__] around you're like oh [__]
this is heavy I was just gonna
emotionally dump on you because you
might open a Floodgate Of some kind yeah
you protect yourself by trying to laugh
and I'm like oh dude you're killing me
right now with that joke man run away
yeah yeah never talk to him again part
that boggles my mind are these dudes who
can find a friend good enough to help
them hide the body and then be
implicated for the whole thing is crazy
to me yeah yeah like there's always a
friend like that that's down to do that
that's a good friend I was like yeah I
just killed somebody would you help me
I'll help Mike keep my mouth shut but
I'm not gonna put nobody in concrete and
cut them up that's crazy yeah yeah
that's a level of friendship I don't
think I can it's already cut up you
don't have to cut off he's already cut
up I cut him already yeah you need help
putting them in the barrel I just get I
have a hard time believing you won't
kill me after the deeds done that's the
other thing too right if you don't help
me and you say something I'm gonna kill
you
[Music]